big guy I know we're having some issues
here but if you're gonna appear at any
moment now it'd be a hell of a good time
No so what you like to fight I don't
hate you you're more in an Avenger than
I am I love you though you don't all
just want to live I want to live too man
I want to live through the let's leave
we'll leave it let me heavenward yes yes
okay again I got an idea
you want to take this one I decided to
show up here we go
hello
that's okay we worked it out in fact I'd
say it's gone from worst case scenario
to I don't know if it's best case but at
least it feels very very manageable now
hear it - how are we doing out there
we're doing okay everyone on my position
we have incoming
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is gonna be my new Avengers infinity
Saga deleted scene for the Hulk a whole
bunch of different plot changes for his
character so we'll break it all down if
you're brand new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos we're
doing a giveaway for that giant infinity
Saga box set of all the movies that's
where this scene actually came from so
it's a big alternate ending and a big
rematch between him and Thanos so we'll
just break this down top eight style
starting with number eight this is
basically one of the Avengers infinity
war alternate endings deleted scenes for
the Hulk it's a huge change from what we
saw in the theatrical cut it would have
also dramatically changed the Hulk
storyline during avengers endgame - I've
already done a bunch of videos for a lot
of the alternate endings for infinity
war and for Avengers end games so I'll
link some of those videos in the
description because there were a lot of
different versions of the movie when
they were riding it and then actually
when they were shooting it to the movies
changed a lot during the process but
number 7 banner tries again to change
into the Hulk while he's still inside
the Hulk buster fighting coal obsidian
during this part of the final battle in
Wakanda before Thanos comes back colab
Citian is beating him and Banner thinks
his only shot is to bring the Hulk out
to stop him he's ripping the Hulkbuster
apart you see him yelling come on Hulk
what are you doing to me here the final
version of this we saw in theaters just
has him saying fine I'll do it myself
then they continue with the rest of the
movie but in this deleted scene version
of the alternate ending they have it out
banner in the Hulk
finally explaining in his own muddled
Hulk speak that he wants to be free to
exist all the time not just when there's
fighting he thinks banner doesn't care
about him and since the initial gamma
accident banners been doing everything
he can to keep the Hulk locked inside
him like a prison he's not lying about
that even though you got the chatty
version of the Hulk during thor ragnarok
they introduced him in the context that
it was him who was sublimating Banner
locking him inside the Hulk so that he
could have all the fun that he wanted
and part of why he enjoyed the contest
of Champions on Sekar so much and didn't
want to leave didn't want Thor to leave
was because the audience showed him so
much luck
they made him feel like he was valued
whereas normally everyone on earth hates
the Hulk that's all you hear like the
Hulk is just this terrible person we
need to lock him up keep him from
destroying everything
so Banner in the Hulk come to an
agreement quote-unquote and even though
they deleted this
before they finish the special effects
that's why it looks like it's ps2
graphics you can tell right after banner
says I got an idea then they cut back to
coal obsidian when you come back to
banner in the hulk they were playing
like a huge professor hulk reveal with
him bursting out of the Hulkbuster wall
coal obsidian was starting to rip it
apart so we start shooting him with the
Hulkbuster because it hasn't been
completely destroyed yet co-op sitting
gets really pissed off and starts to rip
him apart that banner reaches up to stop
him with his arm after he's mostly
destroyed the Hulkbuster and you can
kind of see from the graphics here that
he's already turned into professor Hulk
while he's still inside the Hulkbuster
this is meant to be him as the Hulk
inside the shell of the Hulkbuster and
it's slowly being ripped off so when his
arm reaches up here it's actually the
Hulk's green arm that you see inside the
Hulk buster then just like in the final
version we saw in theaters he defeats
Coe obsidian except this time it's him
as the Hulk throwing him into the energy
shield that was over Wakanda just
blowing him into a million pieces the
number 6 WTF for just a hot minute
banner is looking at his reflection as
Professor Hulk in that stream that he's
standing and just can't believe what's
going on like oh wow we did it we look
totally different this is kind of weird
he saunters back unto the battlefield
just as Stannis is getting ready to
arrive to steal the mine stone getting
ready for a rematch because he got
stomped at the beginning of the movie so
they're still up for a rematch in this
version of the movie there was another
deleted scene of a Hulk vs. Thanos
rematch during Avengers end game which
also didn't make it into the final cut
of the movie so there were a couple of
planned rematches that they had for Hulk
and Thanos one during infinity war which
is part of this deleted scene and then
the other one during endgame but number
five WTF on his way to go fight Thanos
he runs into Black Widow and Falcon just
kind of saunters out of the bushes and
they're like what is going on they
haven't quite realized that he's
professor hope they just still see this
giant green person and are worried about
the Hulk going crazy Black Widow is
getting ready to bust out her son's
getting real low buddy until Banner says
no weight in his banner voice speaking
to them clearly while he's in the body
of the Hulk and it just kind of freaks
them out a little bit wait a minute it's
banner speaking to us not the Hulk
they're kind of like okay you know
whatever whatever is going on now but
shits going down Stannis is getting
ready to destroy everyone so we got to
get back to the battle so number four
then you get to the scene of Thanos
portaling in and the Avengers all
trying to stop him one-by-one at the end
which is kind of swatting them aside
with the power of the Infinity stones in
the theatrical cut that we saw he just
floats the Hulk into the rock base using
the space stone immobilizing him in the
deleted scene version of this it would
have been Professor Hope charging Thanos
for a rematch Hulk would have still lost
the fight it would have just been fan of
swatting Hulk into the rock face
trapping him so that he'd be forced to
watch as he took the mind stone killing
vision then snapping everyone this is
one of those parts of the movie like the
last eight to ten minutes of it that
changed way more than other things
obviously probably one of the most
important parts of the film fan of
snapping half of all life away in the
universe so no surprise that a lot of
different aspects of the way these parts
of the scenes went down so number three
there were a couple other deleted scene
versions of this final gauntlet run that
involved the Avengers attacking him in
slightly different ways there was one
version like a really big version that I
talked about in a video a couple years
ago that was almost the exact same as
the fight scene on Titan where all the
Avengers try to get the gauntlet off of
him but he still manages to snap
everyone away it's just that instead of
him running the Avengers gauntlet one by
one tried to finish his gauntlet it's
them trying to dogpile him the way they
dogpile him during the Titan fight so it
was always going to end with the same
moment of the Avengers losing this big
Hulk scene which is going to happen at
the end of infinity war with him turning
into the combined version of banner and
Hulk and the Russos just decided to push
it into the five-year time gap before
Avengers end game picks up in 2023 so
number two this also would have
subsequently changed the opening scene
of Avengers endgame with the Avengers
killing Thanos on Titan because Hulk was
still in the Hulkbuster formed during
the theatrical version of that you just
have to picture Hulk just bursting in
here just trying to rip him apart
looking for the gauntlet the scene would
have still ended on the same kind of
downer beat like is this really a
victory with Thor going I went for the
head I did what he said this time I
totally went for the head but as you saw
in some of the other deleted scenes
videos that I posted last year like
there was a really big Hulk scene that
they deleted that they then posted when
they rereleased avengers endgame in
theaters at the end of last summer you
have him in downtown Atlanta pretty much
saving a whole bunch of people in his
professor Hulk outfit before he shows up
in the diner that was a whole different
thing so I'll link that in the
description
- so number one WTF the future of the
Hulk character at least the Bruce Banner
Hulk character as for the Hulk after the
Avengers end game ending I've done a few
videos about what's going on with him
during Marvel phase four Mark Ruffalo
came out and publicly said he's coming
back for more Marvel movies and projects
so he's not going anywhere
there'll always be some form of the Hulk
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe and
obviously we're mostly just talking
about the Bruce Banner Hulk but there's
a whole family of whole characters you
have she hooked that they're doing that
Marvel phase for Disney Plus series for
you even have the Thunderbolt Ross red
hope that they might be doing at some
point in the future we haven't got any
confirmation on that it just seems that
there's a lot of Thunderbolts stuff that
they're setting up I'll do more videos
for all that stuff for future Avengers
movies and all the other big Marvel
phase 4 stuff as we get more details but
leave all your video requests and big
questions in the comments below I know
everyone wants to see a Hulk vs.
Wolverine movie because Wolverine
appeared for the first time in the whole
comics everyone click here for that
brand new Avengers infinity saga deleted
scene with Thor and click here for that
video of Mark Ruffalo talking about the
new Hulk movie thank you so much for
watching everyone stay awesome this is
the way
[Music]